the I know and welcome to this  announcement video has already mentioned  last week from today on this Wednesday  we will have the weekly double feature  on chest 24 so it starts off with at 6  p.m. central european time our grits  blitz torches bentyl blitz creek bridge  in german language for 90 minutes and it  continues at 8pm in central europe in  time in english so we have two 90-minute  shows the first one is a german language  the second one in english and this would  be a weekly feature and a promise that  i'm not wearing this red shirt again ok  guys hope you join it's not a long time  since the counter you just go there by  the way to go on the chest 24 website  and nothing that should be easily found  them thanks